DEBI CABRERA:
Today, we're talking
about VMs, cybersecurity,
and our partners.
I'm Debi, and welcome to "This
Week in Cloud," where we serve
you the lowest latency news.
One of the best
aspects of the cloud
is the ability to purchase
and use only what you need.
This enables you
to take advantage
of modern and performant
computing while fine-tuning
cost optimization.
With Suspend/Resume now
generally available,
you have even more control
over your Google Cloud resource
consumption.
You can think of it like
closing your laptop.
Head to the blog
for more details.
As we continue our series on
health care and cybersecurity,
we'll focus next on establishing
sustainable visibility
mechanisms so
cybersecurity teams working
in our global health care
system can secure and preserve
patient care and safety.
Check out the blog
for further details
and more about how health
care can strengthen
its cybersecurity resilience.
Our tech and startup customers
are disrupting industries,
driving innovation, and
changing how people do things.
We're proud of their
success and want
to showcase what they're up to.
You'll hear about
their new products,
their businesses
reaching new milestones,
and their ability to get
things done faster and easier
using Google Cloud's
App Development, Data
Analytics, and AI ML services.
A full list is up on the blog.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.